[Musique]
donc un C&A assez exceptionnel
aujourd'hui vous êtes très nombreux très
contente de vous avoir avec nous Diane
Bérard Nicolas Duvernois Christiane
Bergevin et Jacques Letourneau donc
merci beaucoup d'être là vous avez suivi
sûrement très attentivement la soirée
d'hier je suis curieuse de vous entendre
90 députés pour la CAC avec 40 % des
votes est-ce que la CAC va avoir les
coûts de franges pour le prochain mandat
peut-être commencer avec vous Diane
alors ce que je dirais c'est qu'avec 70%
des députés et 40% des votes c'est clair
que la CAQ a des angles morts à sa
gauche et à sa droite et elle devrait
les surveiller vous pouvez voir comment
ça va comment ça va se dérouler tout
seul parce que il va y avoir des enjeux
d'acceptabilité sociale il faut que la
taxe se prépare Nicolas qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez je crois qu'il faut dans
un système démocratique comme le nôtre
je crois qu'il faut accepter le résultat
et pas changer les règles si le résultat
ne nous plaît pas là on entend tout et
rien sur à quel point il faut réinventer
notre système électoral les Québécois
sont arrivés placer 41% du nombre total
des votes exercées on se rappelle parce
qu'il y a 2 millions de personnes qui
ont décidé de rester chez eux et pas
voter donc c'est énormément de personnes
qui ont donné le pouvoir ou qu'on
redonne le pouvoir à la CAQ et donc oui
ils vont avoir les coups de France
cependant je ferai attention 90 députés
à l'interne il va avoir des petites
guerres pour avancer à droite et à
gauche à devoir
si on peut les coups des franges
maintenant ils auront jamais parce que
sur les 90 députés il y a 60 3 2/3 en
fait de vétérans vétérans alors c'est
des gens qui ont fait un premier mandat
il y a un grand bain c'était une équipe
de hockey et ça permet d'aller d'avoir
des en région en ville moins évidemment
à Montréal moins mais d'avoir des
comités structurants pour notamment voir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre donc en région oui ce sera
un gros enjeu effectivement
je constate que il y a un déficit
démocratique au sens où il y a des
parties qui ont quand même récolté 13 14
15% qui devrait avoir normalement plus
de députés à l'Assemblée nationale mais
on peut pas réécrire l'histoire donc ça
veut dire que monsieur Legault pas
tellement la réputation de gouverner en
consultant alors il va falloir que le
dialogue social soit mis de l'avant je
pense notamment en 100 ans d'éducation
il y a l'éducation ça va être une
priorité la refondation de du réseau de
la santé c'est aussi une priorité ça
peut pas se faire tout seul ça derrière
des porte donc il y a un dialogue à
établir avec les représentants des
patrons des représentants des syndicats
des employés pénurie de main d'oeuvre la
même chose si on veut être capable
d'avoir une stratégie nationale il va
falloir asseoir du monde autour de la
table pour être capable d'avoir une
vision puis des perspectives une chose
qui a marqué c'est le peu de députés de
la CAQ à Montréal hier Régis la Baume
dans notre émission spéciale disait on
assiste vraiment un fossé qui se creuse
Montréal le reste du Québec est-ce que
Montréal ink doit s'inquiéter Christiane
qu'est-ce que vous
on peut regarder ça comme ça c'était
indéniable qu'une fracture entre les
couleurs de nos parties mais moi je fais
confiance à monsieur Legault à son
gouvernement il le dit hier soir pour
représenter le Québec au complet parce
que la prospérité économique du Québec
ça dépend notamment des engins
économiques des moteurs économiques que
représentent les grandes villes mais dès
que Monsieur le baume parle de Montréal
il faut qu'il y ait une flèche quelque
part et je crois que ça l'aveuglé hier
parce que si on regarde ne serait-ce que
une carte couleur de ce qui se passe il
y a pas de Québec il y a quatre Québec
il y a la CAC qui est les couronnes de
Montréal et pas mal toute la province à
Montréal et à l'ouest avec les libéraux
il y a l'Est avec Québec solidaire et
aux alentours de Québec et en Beauce un
peu beaucoup il y a les conservateurs ça
c'est quatre Québec complètement
différents je sais qu'il aime bien
Montréal contre Québec mais là non il y
en a quatre est-ce que vous vous
attendez à ce qui est quand même des
projets de Montréal qui sont un petit
peu difficiles à se faire entendre qui
pourrait peut-être
Montréal est incontournable je veux dire
c'est 30-35% du PIB du Québec ces deux
millions de personnes moi j'ai bien aimé
ce que la mer est plante dit aujourd'hui
il y a quand même trois chefs de
l'opposition il y en a un peu plus dans
l'Est la Camille lorrain PSP il y en a
d'autres du bois qui est au centre puis
dans le Sud-Ouest on a madame Anglade
bon c'est vrai que c'est toujours
préoccupant quand le parti qui est au
pouvoir est aussi peu représenter à
Montréal mais je pense que pour monsieur
Legault je suis d'accord avec Christiane
y aura pas bébé le choix là faut que tu
trouves un chemin pour t'entendre avec
Montréal surtout finir là-dessus tu as
des enjeux notamment de transport
collectif mettons que notamment
notamment puis d'excellentes chambres de
commerce et surtout que le trio
économique comprend très bien
l'importance de Montréal mais
à la santé mais à Monsieur vicksben
Sonia Lebel même si les Trois-Rivières
ils comprennent que c'est on peut pas
faire sans Montréal on a suivi 5 parties
durant la campagne il y en aura quatre à
l'Assemblée nationale comment est-ce que
les parties de l'opposition vont pouvoir
se faire entendre comment vous voyez ça
vous dites c'est intéressant parce que
en fin de journée alors que je m'en vais
dans le taxi il y a eu une nouvelle qui
disait que monsieur Legault tendait la
main aux autres parties donc elle est
consultée Québec solidaire pour
l'environnement le Parti libéral pour
l'économie le PQ pour la langue
française c'est le parti conservateur
pour les institutions donc à quelque
part il y a comme une prise de
conscience de la part de monsieur
Legault du Premier ministre qui doit
travailler avec les autres parties mais
moi ça ne me suffit pas il me semble que
compte tenu de l'étrange résultat
électorale il faut absolument revoir le
principe du temps de parole pour que les
parties les députés puissent se faire
entendre à l'Assemblée nationale au
Salon bleu là où ça se passe ça demande
de changer les règles par contre comment
vous voyez ça d'une élection ça c'est
souvent des promesses de jour de l'angle
ils sont engueulés
de la vitamine C dans le jus d'orange
tout d'un coup le mimosa donc le
champagne c'est correct donc ça fait 30
40 jours qui s'engueulent tout d'un coup
je veux travailler avec tout le monde un
moment donné là
au Salon bleu ça peut pas juste être des
promesses on va se parler entre deux
c'est que les députés représentent
beaucoup plus de votes chaque député
représente beaucoup plus de votes que ce
qu'on pense ou ce que ça a l'air parce
que justement le vote n'est pas
représentatif
de travailler les règles par le menteur
pour permettre davantage d'expression en
provenance de partie qui sont à peu près
pas représentés là malheureusement le
Parti québécois il y a trois seulement
trois députés bon non mais je veux dire
je pense c'est important d'organiser la
vie parlementaire pour refléter quand
même si tu aimes c'est un autre cas
parce qu'il n'est pas il y a personne
d'élustre donc ouais mais comment tu
organismes
je pense que au lieu d'avoir des jeux de
toratoires sans fin durant période des
questions on n'a pas besoin d'être 90
pour faire entendre sur le point de vue
je pense que chaque partie s'y amène un
contenu dans sa période de questions est
capable d'animer le débat et et oui et
puis qu'on est du contenu inspirant et
constructif puis pas des joutes de bébé
aujourd'hui politique partisanes qui
prime donc les parties d'opposition
devrait s'entendre pour lutter en front
commun ce qui ne se fera pas je vois pas
Dominique Anglade puis Gabriel nano
Dubois faire un pique-nique au parc
laurier pour essayer de faire la
stratégie contre Monsieur Lebeau qui est
important c'est la constance donc il
faut que les périodes de questions
soient récurrentes on peut pas dire un
parti tu as une question par trois
semaines quand il se passe plein de
choses pendant ces trois-là
et rapidement j'aimerais vous entendre
on a entendu plein de promesses si vous
aviez en choisis une que vous aimeriez
voir la cape copier d'un autre parti moi
j'aimerais bien que la CAC s'inspire du
Parti québécois et de Québec solidaire
une baisse pas les impôts parce que je
pense que
mais mais je vais quand même m'expliquer
je pense que dans un contexte économique
ou on risque d'aller dans récession et
que le gouvernement doit réinvestir de
façon majeure dans les services publics
les services publics au Québec la santé
l'éducation sont pas au bord du gouffre
sont dans le gouffre les deux à passer
en dessous
alors en dessous du goût donc il faut
que le gouvernement se donne des marges
de manœuvre pour réinvestir donc mais
c'est un souhait évidemment
avec Jacques mais je dirais que
j'ajouterai le volet de l'hydrogène à la
perspective analgique des grands
barrages parce que le fond des
générations les revenus du Québec ça
passe par l'énergie environnement
environnement c'est pas une cause
politique c'est une cause où les 5
parties au lieu de s'engueuler justement
devrait se mettre ensemble puis dire
regarder on va être des leaders
d'exemple et puis le Québec c'est le
paradis de l'énergie verte et donc
l'environnement c'est la priorité pour
de vrai avant de penser à l'avenir on va
penser au présent donc moi j'opte pour
la proposition de Québec solidaire de
créer un fond de requalification de la
main d'oeuvre qui travaille dans
une bonne idée pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI